- Johnny.
Okay, Carter.
I can stay here
all night.
So why don't
you and I cut the crap,
and you tell me what happened
on March 15th?
- And what's in it
for Carter Finley?
- What's in it
for you
is I don't send you back
to jail.
- [sighs]
The guy's name
is Cat Branchman.
I met him downtown at a club
called "The Clutching Kitten."
You may have heard
of it.
It's down on the corner
of Hang and Fur Street.
- Cat Branchman.
So what's a guy
like you
and a guy named Cat--
[sighs]
Okay.
I know what
you're doin', Finley.
You're just using what you see
in my poster.
- I'm not, detective.
I'm telling the truth.
- We'll see how much truth
you tell
after a few weeks
in solitary confine--
- Fine, detective.
You've twisted my arm.
- Now, that's better.
- The guy's name wasn't
Cat Branchman.
- Thank you.
- it was a Chinese guy named
"Mr. Meow."
He's the real
gang boss.
Story went he hung guys
from trees
and took pictures
of them.
- Finley.
- Used to run a club downtown.
A front, of course.
Called it "The Paw and Poster."
- Finley.
- Ran it with a guy named
"Hong in Thar."
- Okay.
Let's try this
one more time.
Finley?
Who do you work for?
- Um...
Coffee.
Mr. Coffee Coop.
- You--coffee coop?
- His name was
"Baldy Tall Man Coffee Coop."
- [sighs]
now you're just talking
about me.
Finley, I'm gonna give you
one more chance.
Who is in charge?
- His name was
"Angry Man."
- [sighs]
- The warehouse is located
in the Diploma
for being a detective.
- I want a name.
- Justin.
- Thank you.
- Hangtree--
- Don't say "Hang."
God damn it,
do not say "hang."
- Hang--
- Nope.
- Hangman Justin Cats...
- Finley.
- Poster.
- Do not say "poster" or "cat."
- Cat Poster.
- Okay, that's it.
I'm losing my patience.
Winslow, get this moron
outta here.
- [sighs]
- I'm losing my patience.
Let's try this
one more time.
I'm gettin too old
for this [bleep].
[groans]
- Well-played, detective.
Well-played, indeed.
- Hey, Carter.
You hang in there.